Je viens me parler alors si tu vas
bien j'ai essayé d'expliquer à la femme que
je n'étais jamais allé à New Castle avant que
nous venons de déménager ici de Londres
je suis ici depuis quelques jours je ne sais pas
où  Je vais bien
j'étais dans le bus c'est parti dans le mauvais sens
nous avons couru nous sommes descendus du bus donc il n'y
avait plus comme si elle ne savait pas
ce que je veux que tu fasses c'est m'écouter d'
accord
le  les dames vous ont dit ce qui est juste il y a des
règles ici des règles que nous devons respecter
d'accord ce n'est pas contre vous ou vous avez
un devoir vous avez probablement besoin d'être ici
à l'heure pour vous expliquer pourquoi je n'étais pas
là à l'heure vous savez quoi  J'adore, je
comprends bien,
mais ce que je comprends maintenant, c'est le
décideur, les décideurs
vont envoyer votre lettre par le porche,
vous allez devoir nous sommes pour ça et
ensuite vous aurez tous les enfants à l'école
demain parce que vous  tu ne peux pas juste te
calmer et écouter les gens quand ils
te brisent à nouveau mec tu sais ce que j'ai
écouté c'est que tu as créé une scène non je
crois  le bâtiment qui est le premier dans cette
file d'attente Humana ce jeune âne signe en
premier allez-y allez-y
maintenant vous pouvez retourner à votre bureau et laissez-
nous signer pour faire le travail que le contribuable
vous paie pour c'est une jolie honte
écoutez  d'accord, cela n'a pas à
vous impliquer, tout le monde essaie de faire
son travail d'oreille et vous créez à nouveau plus
d'une scène